If you watched the solution video, you would have noticed that I
used two different methods for transforming our variable. The first method used
a wrapper right around the variable, and then the second used a
scaling layer. Let's look at the differences between these two plots and
see what the two adjustments really do. I'm going to save this first
plot into log scale and I'm going to save the second plot into
count scale. I'm going to use each of these variables and pass it
to grid.arrange, so that way I can plot them side by side, and
that's why the ncal is equal to two. Running this code,
we can see that we get our two histograms. When looking
at the two plots, we can see that the difference is
really in the x axis labeling. Using scale_x_log10 will label the axis
in actual friend_counts. Whereas using the log10 wrapper will label the
x axis in log units. This is just something to keep
in mind as you make more plots. In general, I think
it's easier to think about actual counts, so that's why I prefer
using the scale_x_log10 as a layer. Now, this does
mean that you'll need to learn the ggplot syntax, but
don't worry, you'll have plenty of practice in lesson
four, and if you're feeling really adventurous, you can add
a layer to any of the plots that you
create. So, take our original histogram for friend count. Let's
just add scale_x_log10 to it, and there you go. You
have it, the new histogram transformed using log base 10.